Lear, the aging king of Britain, decided to divide his kingdom evenly between his three daughters.
First, however, he put his daughters through a test.
He asked each to tell him how much she loves him.
Goneril and Regan, his older daughters, gave him flattering but meaningless answers.
Cordelia, the youngest and his favorite,...
...said she had no words to describe how much she loves him.
Lear was very angry and disowned her.
So Cordelia went to France together with the king of France,...
...who wanted to marry her even without her land.
Lear quickly learned that he had made a bad decision.
His older daughters had betrayed him.
Lear went insane and fled to wander on a heath.
An elderly nobleman named Gloucester was also having family problems.
He too headed out on the heath and met King Lear.
He decided to help Lear in spite of the danger.
But Gloucester was captured, blinded and sent away.
His son Edgar, in disguise, led Gloucester to Dover, where Lear had also gone.
Cordelia, who had married the French king,...
...led the French army to Dover in an effort to save her father.
Edmond, Gloucester's illegitimate son, led the English army against Cordelia.
Lear and Cordelia were captured.
Cordelia was executed in prison and Lear died of grief over her death.